he is a two-time rock and roll hall of
famer and one of the best-selling music
artists of all time he returns to his
residency at caesar's palace tonight and
then kicks off his north american summer
tour in june i can't believe he came
here rod stewart
[Applause]
uh we're here to talk about you this is
a big night for you you're starting your
big world tour for 2022 and you're in
caesar's pal thank you so much
because you got to like fly out of here
you're on stage tonight tonight caesar's
palace well they put it back usually
i'll go on stage at 7 30. they'll put it
back to 8 30. but i still have to do
sound check check all the girls costumes
[Applause]
let's be honest
the show really doesn't start till you
get there well it doesn't but i don't
want to be late i don't like to keep my
customers waiting
[Applause]
i mean rock stars are known for keeping
audiences waiting what is your history
of that over the years were you pretty
prompt with your concert yeah always
yeah it's uh
first of all it's people who paid a lot
of money
they've got babysitters hired cars and
bicycles and they get there on time yeah
you don't want to keep them waiting you
want to get out there before you're
supposed to go keep them happy that's
great because that's not what most rock
stars do well that's that's their
business is not needed
and and how long is the show that you do
tonight will be uh per hour and a half
but we're only allowed to do an hour and
a half at caesar's palace because they
get you off the stage right because
they want you to they want everyone to
go back into the us you know yes spend
the money exactly
[Laughter]
and but on the road it's a little more
if you're not at a gambling casino uh yo
yeah we played two hours 15. that's
amazing what was it when you started
because like you know what the beatles
did when they were 15 minutes 25. yeah
that's what we used to do yeah
yeah that's nuts no it's his nuts and
it's and here you are all these years
later i mean i have your latest album so
glad you went back to making an album a
new material yeah it's fantastic the
hercules album
you sound the same oh you haven't lost
anything
so i look the same yeah uh well your
hair is you know you know
i don't know how to do that do you know
what the the queen of england and i have
got in common we both had the same
haircuts for 60 years
[Applause]
i remember
when i first came out here in 1983 i'd
never been here and i never saw a palm
tree and i looked and i went oh it looks
like rod stewart's head
yeah it does yeah
but
i'm eternally grateful it's still um no
unbelievable um
don't you laugh
and then your show is called the hits at
the airport yeah which is fantastic i
mean that's
that's what people want to see oh of
course yeah and and very few people in
music have
90 minutes or two hours of just the hits
you do yes yeah i mean i've seen you in
concert and there's no good time to go
to the bathroom no absolutely that's you
should put that on the sign rod stewart
right you'll never want to go to the
bathroom
you're never going to go to the bathroom
you know i always say my idols were
you know sam cook you know it's ready
and muddy waters all the really great
black swingers
if i went to see them i would want to
hear their hits i don't really know
stuff really
no that's why i try and get my crowd and
you know you you over the years have
been a sort of equal opportunity
recorder of your own material or other
people you did a lot of covers
but i've gone through the stuff and like
all the big ones
you know maggie may and you wear it well
and hot legs and do you think i'm sexy
and tonight's the night and you know
you those were your songs i feel like
you as a songwriter needs a better
publicist
i don't think it's right yeah i don't
think
the great the greatest publishers
publishers are the people that buy the
records
yes they're the ones they make but i
don't think it's singles i don't think
that people think of you as a songwriter
as much as no
it's what i look like you know look well
what else could i have been for a rock
star
i brought you something
that
that it's been
hanging around my house for 51 years
oh my god
that's my uh and it smells like
is it maggie
i bought that when i was 15. no well
yeah how do you think i got it
he was 15 when he bought this right i
was i was 26. i know but how does it
feel
would you feel anything when you see an
artifact like that that is about
something that was so important in your
life yeah it
when it went to number one
in the uk and america i remember i was
driving through london and it came on
the radio
and it was number one i just turned my
car around and went back to my mum and
dad's little house and gave him the
biggest kiss and they all cried
was made of love
and
and that that song i mean this uh
bitterness that you had about maggie may
you know i don't want to see your face
anymore and you know the morning sun
really makes you look old i mean it's
some nasty [ __ ] stuff in there
it is really nasty it is it really isn't
it's nearly a true story
um
lasted about four seconds
but you're nasty staying on the floor
you